- I don't do any email at all,
which is how I do my work
when I'm actually working.
The only time I do
email is when I fly,
even though it's
what I'm supposed to do.
Because when I'm on the ground,
that's the time to do this.
So you're answer, and
your advantage is time.
You need to outwork
the people that have money.
There's three variables, three
pillars: time, money, talent.
Talent is hard to control.
Money, you don't have yet.
Time is your only friend.
What you do between
7 P.M. and three in the morning
will ultimately probably be
the variable of your success.
Now if you lack talent,
you can work for the rest
your life, you're not gonna win.
So you need to
be smart about that.
And then there's the strategy
of what you're building.
If you're building a
piece of shit, you've lost.
But the thing that's most
controllable in sales is time.
- [Man] Okay, thank you.
- You got it.
- [Man 2] Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- Fine, thank you.
I'm one of the
co-founders of Flavor.
Flavor is an online platform
where everyone between everyone
can sell homemade meals online
to other people
in the neighborhood.
- Interesting, there was
a company that I looked at
several years ago
that had a similar concept.
And I love the theory, go ahead.
- [Man 2] We're now
selling over 100 meals
per day here in Belgium only,
Antwerp and the surroundings.
My question, very obvious,
but how do you build
a sustainable
two-sided marketplace?
So meaning growing both supply
and demand side
at the same time.
- It's hard, it's why
Uber and Airbnb are special.
You need to always
obsess about both.
And the thing that I've seen
most two-way marketplaces,
'cause everybody's the
Uber and Airbnb of X, right?
They over-index on one side or
the other and then it breaks.
The tension of making
both great is all you've got.
So you have to literally,
you basically have to be a
perfect parent of two children.
You actually have to
love both of them equally.
So whenever you feel,
and one of the challenges of
loving your children equally
is they live their lives.
And when one's seven
and one's six, maybe that
six year old is having
a tough time and you're
spending 80% there, because
the seven year old's okay.
But you better not spend
too much time, because then
if you don't spend too much
time on the seven year old,
it might crack.
And that's a
two-way marketplace.
You have to figure out
what the health of both are,
and you have to
equally have, from strategy,
real strategy against both,
and then you have to
adjust on a day-to-day basis
if one is underperforming.
- [Man 2] And probably
start fairly local
and see how it goes there?
- Yeah, nobody's ever
won two-way marketplaces
by going global right away.
They always lose, they raise
too much capital, it's hard.
I loved the way you explained
it, like a hundred (inaudible).
I'm like, okay
good start, you know?
Now the question becomes
what's the addressable market?
How big should and
could you get here?
If that answer is
40,000 meals a day,
you got a lot of work to do.
If that answer is 1,500,
not so long before you start
thinking about where else.
My intuition is it's
closer to 40,000 than 1,500.
So you got a lot of work to do.
- [Man 2] Well yes, yes.
- Yeah.
(audience laughter)
But it's about
keeping the eye on the ball.
And about caring
about both sides,
and by doing, back to time,
unscalable things.
You know everybody wants to
find that perfect ad product
that gets awareness,
but they don't want to go to
the farmer's market
and shake people's hand,
or like, tried-and-true
things always work.
Like you still
have eight good friends
and family members who
don't use your product.
- [Man 2] Probably yeah.
- That's insane, fix that.
- [Man 2] Okay.
- You should have
108 people every day.
Do you know what I mean though?
- [Man 2] I'll start
calling them.
- But you know what I mean?
That's important.
That's important, I think
people forget, everybody's
thinking about scale,
and they're not looking at
what's in front of them.
Like, every single
person you went to school with,
every acquaintance,
like everybody.
How many people are using it
every day, raise your hand?
(group laughter)
How many people have used it?
You got work to do.
I look at that as awesome.
Like that's fun, that means
you have a lot of opportunity.
- [Man 2] It is.
- You know what I mean?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Man 2] Okay, thanks.
- You're welcome.
- [Yannick] Hello.
- Hey.
- [Yannick] I am Yannick
from Seal Jobs.
- How are you?
- [Yannick] Good, thank you.
And I have a more
personal question.
- Good.
- [Yannick] How would you
describe the best
possible startup
CEO/cofounder?
- That's interesting,
so I'm big on sales.
In general, for me
personally, and this is not a
tried-and-true answer, for me.
I love people that have
sold stuff in their life.
There's something consistent
about it that's really
worked out for me
in the last 20 years.
And they could be
tech nerdy, you know they,
the kids I liked coming
up the game with like
ripped music from Napster put
on CDs and sell it in schools.
So it was a little tech, it
was a little product right?
I was baseball cards
and lemonade,
some people
were candy.
So I like sales.
I try to figure out as
hard core as I can,
do they need to do this
because they can't breathe
if they did anything else?
Or are they doing it
because they think there's more
money in it, or
because it's cool now?
I think that 95% of the
startup founders that I meet
are doing it for
the other two things.
They're either doing it cause
they think the most money
is there, 'cause they
get seduced by the exits
they read about.
Or because it's now cool
to be a startup founder.
So I hate the current
state of startup, hate it.
I've not been investing at all
for the last year and a half.
Nothing, I've made a
couple big investments
and things that
I'm really involved in.
But, the kinda stuff that
you guys are mainly doing,
I'm not even taking meetings.
Because I feel like
we have the greatest era
of fake entreprenuership ever.
In the U.S., it just
became so big and powerful
and popular, everybody did it.
And in other places,
it was good for the country,
the region, it was
the right thing to do.
Which is both true,
the problem is it brings a
lot of people into the game
that aren't meant to be.
So my biggest things
that I'm looking for the best
entrepreneur and
founder is are they
an entrepreneur and founder,
or are they acting like one?
And that takes,
and that's too hard.
And unlike the advice I gave
downstairs about hire and fire,
you can't unfire a
$100,000 investment, you know?
And so, I think that I look
for people that are driven,
patient and not fancy.
The amount of people
that are founders of companies
who go skiing on the weekend,
who go to every
marketing meetup event,
who take selfies with
micro-celebrities.
We're in such a bullshit era.
Basically, club promoters have
taken over entrepreneurship.
- It's the truth.
And the reason there's giggles
and head nods is we know it.
Just became cool.
Do you know what a
startup tech entrepreneur
looked like 10 years ago?
Not like this.
And not meaning,
I'm sure there's
some in this room.
But none were attractive,
none were cool.
It was some nerd-ass shit.
Like I got in it pretty early,
and I was like, "Where the,"
It was like,
and I was
friends with everybody.
But this was like geek culture.
Web 2.0 were geeks.
Period, end of story.
If you were a
startup founder in 2006,
you were a geek, geek, geek.
You know what else I look for?
A lot of people are
building tech companies
with no tech person
in their company.
They're an
entrepreneur with an idea,
and they think they can
outsource the development.
And they're in
the tech business.
So there's just a lot
of fake shit going on.
Cool.
- [Yannick] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Hey.
- [Lucie] Hi.
- How are you?
- [Lucie] Fine, thank you.
- Good.
- [Lucie] I'm Lucie,
I'm from BookWidgets.
We have platform for teachers,
where they can
create interactive exercises
for their students,
to motivate them more.
- Love it.
And the content would
be used in the classroom?
Or outside the classroom?
- In the classroom, or iPads.
- Okay. Yep, whatever.
Right, go ahead.
- [Lucie] Well, the problem is
that teachers
are very traditional.
- Yes.
- [Lucie] So my question is,
how do you
convince traditional people
to be not traditional?
- You don't.
You do one of two things,
you either
emphatically, aggressively,
through your sheer will,
and being not politically
correct get them there,
or you wait
until they get there.
You can't fight the market.
Now, couple of questions,
and I don't know the
school system here very well,
is there
anything within the system
that won't let them do that?
Like does the teacher
actually make the decision,
or does she or he
have to play in the rules
of the superintendent,
the government,
is there something else that's
not letting them use it?
It's not that
they don't believe,
it's that they can't,
because they can have an
issue if something happens.
- [Lucie] There
is a little issue.
Actually, a big issue
that technology in schools,
it's not update-to-date,
not every school
has the technology.
But it's getting there,
so we are convincing
the teachers to get,
even one iPad is
enough to use it.
So to convince them to
use an iPad, that's all--
- Can you give them the iPad?
- [Lucie] That's not
our intention--
- Why?
- [Lucie] Just because--
- You haven't
thought about it yet?
- [Lucie] No.
- Okay.
(audience laughter)
- It's okay.
And do you guys
have the money to do it?
- [Lucie] No.
- Right, so I would reach out,
and so I would go home tonight,
and I would send an email
to Samsung, and Apple,
and Microsoft, and Google
and I would ask
one of those companies.
So Windows, Microsoft's
tablet is not doing great.
You might be able to
get 50 of them for free.
Go ask.
And then give it.
And now you've
eliminated one of your problems.
But a lot of startups
will go out of business
'cause they were too early.
And so one of the naive
things that all of us do,
including me,
is we think it's
going to happen faster than
it actually happens.
So you've gotta be careful with
what I heard
really quickly here,
to make sure that
you're not too early.
And if you are,
how do you adjust to stay alive,
until the market comes to you.
You're welcome.
DRock?
No?
Okay, next.
- Hi, Gary--
- Oh I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, brother.
- [Nico] I was
supposed to sit over there.
- DRock fucked you up.
(audience laughter)
Jesus, DRock.
- [Man 3] I was trying to
sit close to you guys.
- Yeah, I get it, I got it.
Too much to the light.
- [Nico] I'm Nico, cofounder
of startup Impovide,
another question for you.
In this globalized world,--
- Yes?
is the USA still an
important market--
- USA?
- [Nico] USA.
- Yes.
For many European startups?
- [Nico] Of course.
Do you expect big impact of
the ambition of President Trump
to protect this market?
- That's a good question.
- [Nico] How can we counter it?
And what for SaaS?
- My intuition is, right now,
and by the way, the answer
is I have no fucking idea,
comma, based on what I'm
seeing him doing right now,
he's more worried about
getting jobs to stay in America
for very old school
construction, manufacturing.
He's worried about the states
that he has to win
in his next election.
So he's more worried
about Ohio, and Pennsylvania,
and Michigan.
And so I don't know.
But I'll be honest with you.
With the amount
of European startups
that have had real
success in the U.S. market,
President Trump
might be your last problem.
(audience laughter)
Do you know what I mean?
- [Nico] Also no borders,
so it he cannot protect it.
- Well, be careful,
anything can happen.
Russia and China have proven
that the internets has borders.
And I take nothing for granted.
Especially,
being born in Russia.
I wouldn't rely on that.
I would remind you
to be more practical,
which is there are not that
many winning startups in Europe
dominating in a U.S.
market environment.
I think your bigger problem
is the other U.S. startups,
that are doing
what you're going to do,
much more than the
President of the United States.
- [Nico] What's the reason
you think for that?
Europeans startups
not making it in the U.S.?
- Well, I think a
lot of it is talent.
I think that one
advantage that U.S. has
is that the most
talented kids from America,
all migrate to Silicon Valley,
and then you
basically have this ecosystem
of a lot of talented
engineers and product people
that are teaming up.
It's just a talent game,
and it's very easy to
move within the U.S. from,
to San Francisco.
So the talent,
I actually think plays out.
I think entrepreneurship
is inherently rewarded
in the United States,
while it's still
historically in Europe,
it's finally chipping away,
it's why I'm so
happy to be here.
But historically,
failing in America,
though tough,
is not a deathblow.
Failing in Europe
is a scarlet letter.
And that has been the death
of entrepreneurship over time,
in Europe.
I think that
there's infrastructure
in history of consumer behavior.
The internet is just,
though you see
interesting things,
like the U.K. market has a
healthier e-commerce business
than the U.S.
market in a lot of ways.
But I think a
couple of those factors,
Venture Capital
money is consolidated,
which is giving a lot of people
the ability to build businesses
that don't have
to be profitable,
and have been
able to get through
and build very big businesses.
And the
infrastructure of communication.
The biggest
websites in the world,
the far majority of
them outside of China,
East-based companies
are based in the U.S.,
and China is a closed door.
So nobody's
really doing much there.
It's insular nationalism.
Whereas a lot of
people are doing it.
Now, that being said,
Spotify, SoundCloud,
there's amazing accomplishments
that have worked over there.
But I think
you're going so macro,
I'm way more
concerned about the micro.
I think you can't focus,
or be crippled by that,
you just need focus on even
being able to win that game,
if that's your ambition.
You know?
The good news is,
if you win that game,
that means that
you've raised a lot of money
from a lot of
very important people,
who will deploy that
political and financial capital
against you staying alive.
To win in the U.S.,
you've built a
billion dollar company.
Unless you're looking
to build a very
practical small business,
and then I would
diversify, period.
Then you don't
need the U.S. necessarily.
Do you know what I mean?
You need the US if
you're going global
and building a
billion dollar company.
You don't need
the U.S. to build a 10,
or even $100 million business.
You got it.
Hey, man.
- [Dries] I'm
Dries from LifePower.
- How are you?
- [Dries] Good, good, thanks.
- Good.
- [Dries] We're building a next
generation of power products
among which an
electric motorcycle.
My question to you is
since time is so limited
and precious for
us as entrepreneurs,
how do you decide
whether or not to go
for a business opportunity
when it presents itself?
For example,
a customer pops up and says,
"Hey, but can't you
do this custom for us?"
and we're like, "That
could be possible, but--"
- But it takes away
from our core mission.
- [Dries] Exactly.
- So classic.
It's a go or no go strategy.
- That is gonna be
predicated on how good you are.
- [Dries] Okay.
- Those are decisions
I can't make for you.
There's not tried-and-true.
There's been plenty of
people who did a side project,
customized, which did two
things: gave them the money
to stay alive and
showed them something
they never thought of
which then built
their biggest product.
Then, there's been
companies that got distracted
and became an agency in
the client service business
and missed their opportunity.
Both have
happened a trillion times.
No guy from the U.S.
who's been successful
is gonna tell
you the right answer.
You're gonna make those calls
and your success is
gonna be predicated on it.
You know what the
best part about that is?
That's the way it should be.
That's what capitalism
and meritocracy is.
How good are you?
Did you make the right call?
'Cause they're both right,
but they're not
both right for you.
Question is will you make the
right call when it matters?
- [Dries] We'll see.
- We'll see.
But that's the answer.
Don't be crippled by it and
more importantly, don't--
(laughing)
- [Dries] Fast, make that
decision really, really fast.
- [Man] Flip coin.
- They're literally
potentially both right.
If it doesn't
come to you right away,
it's only gonna get harder.
The more you sit on something,
it gets harder, not easier.
- [Dries] True.
- People think like
they're gonna figure it out.
They're gonna figure
it out by tasting it.
Should I eat this cherry?
Will I like it?
The right strategy is
to fuckin' eat the cherry.
Right?
Then you'll know.
Truth is, you
should probably do both.
- [Dries] If we can,
but if we can't.
- If you can.
- [Dries] That
works a couple of times,
but if a tenth person
is ringing at your door,
it's like, oh.
- Yeah, but then if the tenth
person's ringing at your door,
you need to
figure out why the fuck
they're ringing at your door.
Maybe the right move is
to actually build a business
that does do that
and is highly profitable
so that you have cash
when the world dries up of cash
and you're not at the
mercy of VCs and raising money,
but you actually made
cash 'cause you were an agency
for four years and then you're
37Signals and Jason Fried
which is they were an
agency and they converted
into their product and
they became a huge business.
People are fancy.
People when they have
nothing say dumb shit like,
"Yes, but the economics are
in building our own product,
"not in services."
You don't have anything.
- [Dries] Yet.
- Yet.
But the best way to
have something is actually
do something
that's bringing you money.
- [Dries] Good choice.
- I think so.
- [Josef] Hi, Gary.
- Hey.
- [Josef] I'm Josef for Audiome.
We do iPhone repair
on location, on spot.
- That's cool.
- [Josef] My question for
you was how do you expand?
- How quickly?
- [Josef] Like in 30 minutes.
- Great.
- [Josef] How do you
expand in new cities
without being there
yourself to promote it?
- By being there
yourself through either you
or the person you
trust the most in the world.
The end.
When Travis was expanding Uber,
he either went to the market
or Ryan Graves
went to the market
'cause he trusted him the most.
- [Josef] Okay.
- And he did that
for five or six markets
until Patrick in Chicago showed
that he was worth trusting
and now Patrick
and Ryan and Travis.
Everybody's trying to scale.
Scaling the unscalable is how
you get to the point of scale,
so either your number
two has got Belgium on lock
and you can go to Paris
or she or he can go to Paris,
but don't hire
somebody on a whim
because you don't know
what you're dealing with
and then you lose.
Or you can win.
- [Josef] Yeah, yeah.
- But you're risking it.
I don't think opening a
new market is worth risk
'cause it can take you down.
So what I like
to do is over hire.
I would probably hire
an extra person or two here
and really start testing and
tasting and understanding them
to be ready to
move one of 'em there.
- [Josef] Nice.
- If you're only in one market,
I'd probably move
to the second market.
- [Josef] Thanks.
- You got it.
- [Nicholas] Hi, Gary.
- Hey, man.
- [Nicholas] I am
Nicholas from Plannr.
- How are you?
- [Nicholas] I'm really good.
I'm really grateful to
be here right here with you.
- Thanks, bro.
- [Nicholas] We created
a solution for businesses
to make group meeting
scheduling a lot more easier.
- Okay.
- [Nicholas] My
question for you is
how can you use storytelling
in a more B2B setting?
- Okay.
Let's go back to the product.
What are you solving?
- [Nicholas] The problem
of scheduling meetings,
but more like for
businesses 'cause for example,
I'm a consultant.
- Yes.
- [Nicholas] And if I
have to work in the company,
I need to meet with the CEO,
meet with the marketing advisor,
and they all have
really busy schedules.
With my tool, I can
just send you one invite,
it takes 30 seconds,
and we find the perfect
moment to have that meeting.
- Are you integrated
into Google Calendar's API?
- [Nicholas] Of course.
Google Calendar,
Office 365, Exchange, iCloud,
all of the big players and we
even have really smart plugins
that work in your
Gmail, in your Outlook.
One click and that's it.
- Got it.
Look, it takes all that data
and surfaces up what
the right opportunity is?
- [Nicholas] Yeah, it takes
the data in your calendar,
but also your location,
your travel time,
your personal preferences,
like a sniff of AI on top
to make like all the stuff
that your personal assistant
would do, we do that for you
and just pick the right moment.
- If you put in the inputs or
through only API integrations?
- [Nicholas] Yeah,
we use the information
that's in your calendar already.
- Got it.
So you're trying to figure out
how to build top-of-the-funnel
awareness for the product?
- [Nicholas] Yeah, but
I really like the concept
of storytelling and I would
like to use it somehow
in our B2B marketing strategy.
- Right, so storytelling in
the way that you want to do it
comes in the form of
making a three-minute video
that is a scene out of a sitcom
that shows how your
utility fixes the problem.
- [Nicholas] Yeah.
- So what I would do is like,
I don't know if you guys
have "The Office" as a show?
Good.
So I would make
a four minute video.
Here's storytelling.
You make a four minute video
that starts with an executive.
You just tell the story, right?
The executive's like,
"Fuck, I need to see Karl,
"but where's he?"
You just show the
problems or it's a scene
of two administrative assistants
having a beer and saying,
"You know what
really fuckin' sucks?
"When you've got
to schedule all three
"senior vice presidents
and they're all
"in three different markets."
You've basically got to
show a scene from a movie
or a sitcom, then you make
the video, then you run ads
on Facebook against
employees of the companies
that you're trying to sell to.
Then, people will see the video
and then they'll share
it with the decision maker.
- [Nicholas] Cool.
- That's just tangible
black and white B2B marketing.
Employees of
segmentation in Facebook is
one of the great underused
marketing tactics in a B2B
world.
So for example, if you
were selling a B2B product
and you're trying to get
to the CIO, you make a video
that the opening
line of the video is,
"Does your CIO know?"
If you do that, if
the person who watches it
is in a different department,
but they think it's interesting,
they click one button and
they share it with the CIO.
This is LinkedIn's
miss right now
and Facebook's opportunity.
If you care about storytelling,
then you go for humor.
- [Nicholas] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or sad.
In storytelling, there's
tried-and-true emotions.
Humor, fear, sadness,
inspirational, you know.
Paint a picture.
Show me.
- [Nicholas] Cool.
- Right?
- [Nicholas] Yeah.
- Two people
walking into office,
getting coffee at nine o'clock.
How's your day?
Gonna suck.
Yours?
Gonna suck. Why?
He's traveling to 14 cities
and I have nine
meetings to make.
Me too.
Two secretaries,
guy and gal talking.
Duh, duh, duh, duh,
duh, some nerd kid comes up.
He's like, "Why don't you use,"
what's the name of your company?
- [Nicholas] Plannr.
- "Why don't you use Plannr?
"What the fuck is Plannr?"
Duh, duh, duh,
duh, duh, duh, duh.
Everybody's happy.
(audience laughter)
Got it?
- [Nicholas] Yes, very good.
- Cool.
- [Nicholas] Thank you.
- [Ruben] Hi, Gary.
- By the way, real quick,
that's how Dollar Shave Club
created a one
billion dollar company.
One video.
Now, that's hard.
You might have to make 11
videos before that happens
and that might
cost you so much money
you go out of business,
but that's what it takes.
- [Josef] Okay, okay.
Hi Gary, I'm Ruben.
I hope you're enjoying
your time in Tech Summit.
- [Gary] I am,
thank you brother.
- [Ruben] Nicholas
already explained a bit
about the product, but
what I really want to know is
since you like predictions,
for B2B companies,
what are the new big players
in social media landscape
and how to define which
to use for your company?
- [Gary] B2B has
the same opportunity
and has the same
platforms as B2C,
but not every product works for
B2B the way it does for B2C.
So for example, Snapchat.
Snapchat's very
effective in the U.S.
It's very big,
obviously it's lost some steam
because of
Instagram copied features,
but it's still much bigger.
I mean people are so
funny, people are so lazy.
They're like "Oh it's dead!"
Yes, it's dead.
Hundreds of
millions of active users!
Super dead! Ya know?
Might not work for
every single company
because the target of
who they're trying to get to
might not be using Snapchat.
But, if they are,
so for example,
if you guys decided the people
that actually would use Plannr
are actually 20 to
30-year-old admins.
Now you're saying
"maybe they are on Snapchat."
Now, you know that
there's an open API.
There's an open
platform now where
Snapchat allows you
to make custom filters.
It's one of the
great deals of all time.
You wanna win
in the U.S. market?
It's five dollars for
20,000 square feet
for an hour.
So I don't think
this is open for here yet,
but if it was, or when it was,
I could have put a
filter for my B2B company
over all 300 people here,
let's say 80 of them used it,
for all three hours
that events were going on,
it would have cost
me $15 and the time that
me to create a filter,
and the 31 coolest people here,
youngest, most tech savvy,
would have seen my
filter, and that probably
would have been worth $15.
Or, I promise you
when it opens up here,
and now let's get
even more interesting,
there's an enormously big
match for your national team,
and you know the 15
biggest bars or pubs
or gathering places,
and now you buy it there
and that's just
general awareness.
That's just brand marketing.
So, nobody's thinking
that Snapchat's good for B2B
but what if the
biggest conference
for secretaries
and admins in the world
is happening in Hong Kong and
you buy your filter there?
(Ruben laughs)
Do you see?
People, I said it downstairs
and I'll say it here.
The key. back to your
first question my man.
The key for
if you're an entrepreneur
startup founder
of a young company,
you have to be the architect,
you have to be the
general contractor,
you have to be the mason,
the plumber, the garbage man.
The reason I am so fearful
of startup founders right now
is everybody wants
to be the architect.
You know?
You gotta be the executor.
The reason I have
so much bravado
around my
social media strategies
is I'm a practitioner,
I use it every day.
Everyone one of 'em.
Lots of them. Always.
You know?
And that's a big deal.
So, to be good at marketing,
you have to be doing marketing.
You have to try these things.
I would say that Facebook is
number one, two,
three, four, and five.
(group laughter)
- [Ruben] Just one prediction,
the one next, here
- [Gary] I don't,
you know what's funny?
People think I
predict, I don't predict.
I just move quickly
when it's happening.
- [Ruben] Yeah
but you recently said
Musical.ly is
the way to go for B2C
- [Gary] Yeah
after 40 fuckin' million
kids downloaded Musical.ly.
(group laughter)
- [Ruben] But it's not as
big as in here, as in--
- [Gary] Yeah, I mean here,
by the way,
the greatest advantage
of being in Belgium
is you get to see the
future and just do it here.
Now, not every time,
Pinterest doesn't always
become huge here,
but it's worth the risk.
You should move fast on
every U.S. platform every time
because all you
need is one of them
to be the next Facebook or
Twitter or
Instagram or Snapchat,
or whatever, I know Twitter
never popped here asmuch
but all you need is one, and
it was worth all 15 failing
because the 16th time paid for
all the other times combined.
- [Ruben] Okay.
- [Gary] Got it?
That's how I predict,
I just use 'em all,
and then I look like a genius.
(group laughter)
He did it!
And I'm like "Yeah, you didn't
talk about social camera,
you know, remember Vine?
But, here's what's
funny, it's like a hit show.
Vine is dead, but I got
a lot of value out of Vine.
For the 13 months
that it mattered,
I got what I needed out of it.
Everybody wants all these
platforms to last forever,
but they don't want
every television show
to be number one,
to run commercials.
You just run commercials
when it is number one.
- [Ruben] Thanks.
- [Teegan] Hi,
my name is Teegan.
I'm here on behalf of
GingerWald
which is a B2B cold-pressed
juicing company.
- Very cool.
- [Teegan] I do their marketing.
The reason why they
contacted me is basically
because I have a Facebook
page with over 36K likes,
which is something.
- Yep.
- [Teegan] It covers all
the hip spots in Antwerp,
so if you don't know
where to go tonight look it up.
(group laughter)
- I will.
- [Teegan] Anyway, I
kind of feel like a fraud.
- Because?
- [Teegan] Because I
don't know how to generate
money out of my Facebook page.
- Yep.
It's really hard.
I have the impression that
nobody wants to pay for content,
or ads, they're
willing to pay for ads.
But the numbers for ads are
way higher than
you have for content.
I'm asking, basically, for
example, for GingerWald,
how can I sell myself to them?
I mean, I already
sold myself to them,
that's not the question.
But the question is-
- How do you stay there?
- [Teegan] How do I stay there?
- How do you provide value for
what you're being paid for?
- [Teegan] Yes.
- First of all, the
fact that you care about that
already puts you way
ahead of everybody else.
So that makes me happy.
I don't know.
I always say sell
your truth, right?
You heard that.
I agree with you.
I think it's funny that
we're in this era right now
where a lot of
people are getting hired
just 'cause they're
young or they've got pay dirt
and hit some magic on some
sort of social media account.
Then traditional companies
just think that's the magic.
It's very hard to
generate money from anything,
not just social media, from
print and radio and television.
So I think that being up front
with the client
is always the best.
I think I don't
have a great, so,
are you looking
for the short term,
is the real question
just a very short term,
practical answer of how
to drive business for them,
or are you going more macro?
- [Teegan] Actually,
I was looking up stuff
and I read a bunch
of articles online.
I think they're really
focused on U.S. market,
and I was actually
wondering if there might
be a cultural difference.
For example, that Belgians
aren't really interested
in paying for
content on social media
because they have the
impression-
- When you say
paying for content,
you mean the
generation of creative?
- [Teegan] For example.
- Well, Belgians are paying
tons of money for content.
- [Teegan] That
wasn't my impression.
- Yeah, so your
impression's wrong.
There's a ton of companies
paying creative agencies money
to produce pictures
and videos to put out
on social networks.
How many companies
have you talked to?
- [Teegan] A bunch.
I mean, for my page, or for-
- No, so one more time,
I want to really
know what you're asking,
'cause you're dancing,
which is cute,
but I wanna
answer your question.
Are you asking for people
to sponsor
creative on your page?
What are you asking me?
- [Teegan] Okay, so for my page.
- I can't answer
you if you don't ask me.
- [Teegan] No, so for my page-
- Fine.
- [Teegan] I mainly
talk about restaurants,--
- Yes.
- [Teegan] ask them to
pay to put content
about their
restaurant on my page.
- And they say no
How many restaurants
have you asked for money?
Tell me the number,
bunch isn't interesting.
- [Teegan] About a hundred.
- And how many
restaurants are in Belgium?
- [Teegan] All of them.
- Good, go ask all of them.
Even if you're
zero for a hundred,
you need to figure out
if you're zero for 40,000.
How much are you asking for?
Can it be performance based?
So, for example, what
are you pitching them?
Because if
you go into a restaurant
and say the following,
"Hey, Mack.
"I cover your restaurant,
I like your restaurant.
"Let's make a deal.
"You're gonna pay me
500 bucks for three months
"to put out some
original content,
"but I'm gonna
assure you 15 clients
"because I'm gonna do a call
to action for a free beer,
"and then you'll make it up."
If you're just walking
in and say, "Hey, Mack,
"pay me 500 bucks
for pictures and videos
"on my Facebook
page," he may say no.
But if you say,
"I'll give you the money back
"if you don't get 15,"
maybe he'll say yes.
Maybe what you're trying to
sell isn't interesting to them.
Also, maybe you haven't asked
the other 7,000 restaurants
and you just serendipitously
got zero out of a hundred,
but the next batch
of hundred you get 11.
Or maybe you're
asking for too much.
- [Teegan] I highly doubt that.
- I believe you.
So what are you asking for?
- [Teegan] I'm just asking
if they wanna post
on my Facebook page,
I'll provide for
the pictures, the copy...
- And how much
are you asking for?
- [Teegan] Like, the number?
- Yes.
- [Teegan] Euros, 150.
- And they're saying no?
- [Teegan] And
they're saying no.
- And you're zero for a hundred?
They just don't believe you.
You gotta figure that part out.
That happens to
youngsters all the time.
Youngsters always ask me,
"How do I sell because
they think I'm too young?"
I'm like, "You don't."
You don't convince people.
You're not gonna walk in
with a gray-haired wig.
So I think, remember,
don't try to sell somebody
who's not sellable.
You're dealing with
small, traditional businesses.
A lot of those people are
saying no to their own children
to do Facebook marketing,
let alone you coming
out of nowhere and
wanting 150 bucks for it.
Got it?
- [Teegan] Mhmmm.
- Here's what I would do.
I would do a post
on a single restaurant
and do unbelievable writeup
about the single best drink
or meal they have and
push hard your entire audience
about go in
Friday and order this.
And then I would call
Saturday morning and find out
how many of those they sold.
If you call in Saturday
morning to Mack and go,
"Hey, Mack, did you sell a bunch
of french fries yesterday?"
He's like, "Fuck, we did."
You're like, "No
shit, dick, I did that."
(audience laughter)
- [Teegan] Okay, fair enough.
- Different strategies.
- [Hans] Hello, I'm
Hans from Temple Twin.
We are frustrated by the
state of advertisements still.
There's a lot of push still.
But we see a lot of
opposition to this change
that is coming.
- From the client
or from other agencies?
- [Hans] From agencies, yeah.
From media partners that
we are trying to convince.
- Yep.
What're you selling them?
- [Hans] We're selling
them, well, our approach is
that it will be
better for all parties--
- No, I understand the
thesis, what do you do?
- [Hans] We sell them
advertisement space,
but in a
consumer-friendly approach.
- What is it?
Where, how, what?
- [Hans] Well, it's not in
the middle of your movies,
or in the middle of your music,
but it's time that you pick
like on the breakfast
table or on the toilet,
a lot of our
users use on the toilet.
You watch or you get
inspired by commercial messages
and you get credits
that you can exchange
for Spotify Premium or Netflix
or something like that.
- So I personally
hate your business model
even more than theirs.
(audience laughter)
I'm being honest with you.
But I could be wrong.
But I've looked at "incentivized
marketing" for 40 years.
I hate the idea that the
only reason you're watching
my video of this, is
'cause you actually want
Spotify credits.
And that's what
I believe the model
of incentivizing
advertising looks like.
So, I'm probably not the
guy to give you the model
to convince people
because I've talked
a lot of my clients out of it.
If I'm reading
what's right, I feel like
that's what I'm hearing.
Now, every business
that I've seen in that world
has short-term victory and
long-term down,
and so, again, if you
just think about the thesis
of what you're saying,
you're asking a consumer
to consume an
"inspirational message"
or whatever you wanna call it,
that was very
clever and I liked it,
but the only reason
that person is watching,
especially, are you your
own platform, your own app
or thing of that nature?
That's even crazier.
The only reason
somebody's downloading it
is to go through that
motion to sell their time
in return for
something they actually want.
The last thing they're
actually giving the advertiser
is their attention.
You're just whoring
out that transaction.
- [Hans] We have a
nice numbers with our--
- Of course you do.
- [Hans] 1200 users--
- No, no, you have nice numbers,
but are you actually
getting people to buy
my grapefruit soda is
a very different thing
from a branding
standpoint because the intent
of the interaction
was not for that.
I hung out with this
person 'cause I wanted
to date that person.
There's nothing
good happening here.
(audience laughter)
By the way, by the way,
let me just say this;
I've been wrong
about a lot of things,
but as you can tell, I'm
very passionate about this
'cause I've looked
at it for a long time.
I'm just not a big
fan of incentivizing
advertising consumption
because of something else.
I want you to buy my
grapefruit fuckin' soda
not to get credits
to buy an Apple iPhone.
- [Hans] But the focus in the
app is not only credits,
but it's a nice
side effect, that's it.
- But it's the engine
that drives it, right?
- [Hans] It's part of the drive.
- Yeah.
So you're trying to
convince media spending agencies
to drive dollars into you guys.
Yeah I mean look,
I would definitely go through
very hardcore performance
based agencies.
If you go to the
media-centric people,
they're gonna be more
in the branding, right?
I think the people that
are real digital performance
media buyers,
they'll look at metrics
and make a math decision,
not an emotional decision,
and I think you'll
have more opportunity there.
- [Hans] Yeah good because we
have nice return on investment--
- Correct, correct, correct.
You're gonna win
that game because
people have to,
you're forcing them to,
watch the whole video before
you get the get the free stuff,
which for me as a
marketer means you didn't
accomplish the goal, but
for all the math marketers,
you appease them
in the short-term.
- [Hans] Thanks.
- Yeah.
You know, and I want you to win,
but I can't bullshit
you how I feel about it.
- [Hans] Sure,
that's why I'm here.
- I appreciate it.
But go to the performance only
'cause that's who'll go for it.
- [Hans] Thanks.
That was the last one.
- [Man 4] I'm
actually an oldened career
compared to most
of the people here.
- Thank God, me too.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 4] What would you
recommend, by the way,
what do you think of your soda?
- Mm, I like it.
- [Man 4] It was my company's.
Is that right?
(audience laughter)
Phew, that woulda been
even worse than that, right?
I like it, I like
grapefruit flavors.
- [Man 4] So what do you
recommend old entrepreneurs?
Because, yeah, I got a
family, I got all the things
which the young guys don't have.
- Mhmmm. So,
I understand the circumstances,
I actually don't think
they're any different, right?
You have experience, you may
have some wins under your belt.
You may have different
things that they don't have.
I'm not worried about what one
has, what one doesn't have.
My question is what're
you asking specifically.
Like what do you wanna do?
- [Man 4] Well I jumped, so
I did it, I'm going through it.
- So you were doing what?
- I was marketing
director for a big companies.
- Got it, and you
decided to start your own brand?
- [Man 4] Correct.
- Awesome.
And so what's happening?
- [Man 4] It's going very well.
Good.
So what next?
- [Man 4] Okay, people
around me say, "You're 48.
"You're starting
a business now?"
- Sounds like losing players.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 4] Good, okay.
- Is that good enough?
- [Man 4] Yeah, no that's fine.
Sometimes you doubt yourself,
well not doubting yourself,--
- I get it.
- [Man 4] because you know
what you want to do.
But yes, you are 48--
- Here's what's
happening, it's interesting.
You're very
interesting to me, here's why:
you either were an entrepreneur
and you suppressed it
to do the practical thing and
work in corporate America,
or you were kind
of maybe 50/50 right?
Like you had
safety but you also had
entrepreneurial tendencies.
You weren't 100% purebred.
Like for me, I would die.
You know, like I can't breathe
if I'm not entrepreneuring,
and I mean,
since I was like nine.
I mean that's why I got
very bad grades in school.
This wasn't, "It's cool now,"
I was disaster in school
and the immigrants got A's,
that's how you got out,
you know?
So what's interesting is,
the reason you're letting
outside forces seep
in is 'cause you're not,
when you're 100%,
you don't give a fuck.
You're crazy to begin with.
The whole thing's crazy, right?
So if you're in-between,
I would tell you this,
let the results and
the way you feel speak.
The last people you should be
listening to is anybody else.
If you feel it.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- [Man 4] Yeah, I know.
- I mean, now, if your
whole circle, if your spouse,
if your parents, if your
siblings, if your best friends
are all pushing,
"Hey, hey," it can get hard.
What I would say is
find an outlet for support.
Keep hanging out
with these people, right?
Offset the voices.
You need the other voices.
Watch content from other people.
Like if you need that.
So I don't.
I don't consume anything
'cause I don't need ideas
or a reformation or
motivation from anything.
I keep insular, but
if you're feeling it,
and I understand
because you're practical, right?
You feel a huge
sense of responsibility?
- [Man 4] That's correct.
- And so you're always
thinking, "What could go wrong?"
I would remind
you a couple things.
Did you have a fairly
successful corporate career
being a marketer?
Good.
How long has this been going?
- [Man 4] Two and a half months.
- And how's it going?
- [Man 4] Very good.
- Good.
It sounds like
you're just a winner
and so if you happen to
lose here, which we all do,
I have a funny feeling
you're going to be able
to go get a job.
- [Man 4] Yeah, yes,
but I want this.
- No shit,
that's why you did it.
But you have to understand
upside versus downside.
The upside is
you build a whole life
around something you
wanna do and it's the best
and you make more
money and you're happy
and you're doing your thing.
The downside is the
other thing you left.
So as long as
you're not worried about
what everybody says
about you losing here,
if you have to go back,
then you're risking nothing.
Yeah.
- [Man 4] Nice.
- You got it.
- [Man 5] Alright,
so we have some time,
because,
actually you make time go
slower
(snaps)
(audience and Gary laughing)
People can ask four
questions or there are...
- Yeah.
- [Man 6] Well,
talking about content creation,
and content marketing,
when do you think,
you for instance,
upload a lot of stuff.
- Yes.
- [Man 6] When does
a lot become--
- Too much?
Based on how good you are.
So it's in
parallel with quality.
Quantity axis
curve of too much is
when you're not good enough.
For some reason, the
numbers show me that,
even though I'm saying
the same thing over and over,
as you guys can tell in here,
especially the ones
that are closest to me,
I'm so improv, it comes so
natural to me as a communicator,
I can still say
it in different ways,
paint different pictures,
and it makes it interesting.
And maybe this analogy
finally got you to understand,
or maybe that analogy
finally got you to understand.
It's the reason
I continue to do Q&amp;A.
Left to my own way, I'm gonna
get into the same patterns.
When I realized that,
I started forcing more of this,
because you're forcing me
into new ideas, new thoughts,
teaching me
different analogies, right?
So, it's too much if
you have nothing new to say,
or nothing to say
that's relevant in a new way.
Yeah, I mean, notice
how there's not a lot
of blog posts for me?
I finally figured out my team,
they team transcribe,
and I've got some
blog posts of my words,
but I'm not a talented
communicator in a written word,
so I don't do it, right?
So you also have to know
your skills in communicating.
A lot of you have
a lot of good ideas.
You should be taking
them, taking your phone,
recording it, and
putting it out in the world.
You know how a lot
of you have good ideas?
First of all, the
amount of people in here
who have a lot of good ideas
and aren't even recording it
for themselves to use later,
they're just letting it...
That's really one of
the other big reasons
I started doing DailyVee.
I was like, fuck, there's a
lot of good shit I'm saying.
(audience laughter)
And I mean for me not just
for you, that I'd like to have.
And then it became
like, man, all those things
I said back in 1996,
1999, 2003, 2000...
You think I've got a
good thing going now,
if I'd been doing
this from the beginning,
fuck, you would think
I did predict the entire...
I fuckin'...
(audience laughter)
I mean, now there's
some things that were wrong.
I remember for four months,
I was massively passionate
that all email
would become video.
(audience chuckling)
But that would be fun too.
You know, when everybody puts
me too high on a pedestal,
I'd play that video and
be like, "what about that?"
You have to balance, you know?
But I think the
market decides too much,
and I think some
people have one move,
people have one million moves,
just gotta figure out
where you sit in that.
Some people are
better off writing
a very thoughtful
ten thousand word essay
once every two months that
everybody looks forward to,
'cause they're a great writer.
You can see, I'm fast.
I can give real
business advice, (snaps)
I'm really in it, I can do this.
And shit, a lot of
times it's really right too,
I'm a good entrepreneur, right?
But I can't write an
amazing 20,000 word expo.
Do you know how sad
I am, I can't do that?
Some of my thoughts,
I never fully get there,
they get to 73 percent,
but I don't have the ability
to make it deep
enough, 'cause I'm just...
You know?
And so, sometimes it takes
me two or three years,
document over create. How many
of you heard that from me?
Document over create?
Great, so that took
me a long time to get to.
Maybe seven years,
but it was the thing
that really unlocked
it for a lot of people.
Just for a lot of you, my
point on creating content,
is, instead of trying
to think what you make,
just document
everything you're doing.
Do you know that
two or three of you,
if you just documented the
journey of figuring this out,
that people would watch your
video on YouTube everyday,
of you trying to
figure out the school system,
and that in itself is
what would build your business.
- [Man 2] A story.
- Yeah, it's a story, it's the
journey of an entrepreneur.
The legacy that I'm
creating with DailyVee?
Fuck, you know how
cool that's gonna be
when there's ten
years worth of my everyday?
(audience laughter)
Especially if I pull
off very big things?
You know how fun it would
be to watch the three years
before "Drake" became
famous, everything he did?
You know how
fascinating that is?
You know how cool it
would be the watch everything,
especially Steve Jobs, perfect.
I'm not at that level yet,
(audience chuckling)
but I would tell you
that I'm in the
same place right now.
Steve Jobs had Apple,
then he got kicked out,
then he had a
failure called NeXT, failure.
And then he came back to Apple
and it all went crazy, right?
It would've been
awesome if he did daily vlog
for that last year of
NeXT, that in between year,
and that first year
when he launched the iPod.
Fuck, we'd all
watch it, everybody.
So there's a lot, you know.
And by the way, even if it
never changed your business,
do you know how
much fun it would be
for your granddaughter
to watch you do it?
Really, think about life.
You know how
inspiring that would be?
She'd be like, "damn,
grandma was a huslter."
(audience laughter)
"I wanna be one too."
No, really, right?
You know how much fun it
would be for me right now
to see my dad making
two dollars an hour in 1979
waking up at 4:30,
driving, working 15 hours
in a liquor store
and then coming back?
That's cool.
So, I don't think we
think long-term enough,
what it really means.
You know, I look at
stuff now, I'm like,
"Oh, man, I was so young."
"Oh shit, I was
pretty fat," you know?
It's cool.
It's why I do it.
Yeah, let's do it.
Hi
- [Man 7] Hi.
15 years ago
I was lucky enough
to invest in nerds.
- Nerds candy?
- [Man 7] Nerds, no no.
- No what?
Nerds. I was like
that's super cool.
I love Nerds candy.
Got it. Yep.
- [Man 7] First of all,
thank you
for inviting this
guy and paying for him.
(audience laughter)
In those 15 years
and again yesterday
I realized that
the biggest pains
in building up confidence
are also the biggest assets.
What's your
biggest pain in your story?
- [Gary] So I want to make sure
I'm interpreting your question.
The adversities that
lead to the successes?
Give me an example
of one of yours so I can
use that as a proxy
to give you my answer.
- You mentioned
about, not your family,
but your environment.
This old guy, colleague
of mine, also shared it.
- [Gary] Adversity?
- [Man 7] I don't believe
that you can
become an
entrepreneur, sorry for all
those who are dreaming about it.
- [Gary] I agree.
I think it's a natural--
- [Man 7] You are or you aren't
but besides that
what I meant is it's hard.
You can't show
that you are in pain.
Yesterday I was in pain.
- Do you know how many
people have committed suicide
in the tech startup community in
the last five years and
there's not a peep about it?
Tons.
- I don't want to.
(audience laughter)
- I personally know
of more than a handful
and I know that
I'm not looking for it.
I know that Warton,
one of the leading
startup, entrepreneur
schools in the U.S.,
suicide rate has
doubled each year with the
growth of this
because entrepreneurship is
on the pedestal and
everyone thinks it's easy.
It's the loneliest,
it's his emotion,
you know how hard that is?
There's no blaming anybody.
If this wins, you.
If this loses, you.
That's lonely as fuck.
That's why I keep saying, you
know what the best game is?
To be the number 2.
You get a lot of the money.
You get a lot of the action
but you don't get that.
Right?
Rick, I was just
number 2. Rick fucked up.
He was the CEO.
I was just the COO.
I told Rick.
- [Man 7] Again,
not to interrupt you--
- Yes sir? Please.
- [Man 7] You know you're doing
the same thing as a girl.
You're dancing
around professionals ...
(audience laughter)
- Yeah, I'll tell
you why I'm dancing.
- [Man 7] Sorry.
- No, I appreciate what you did.
The reason I'm
dancing is because
I don't think you know
how purebred I really am.
I'd be lying to you. I
don't wanna lie to you.
I feel like you
deserve an answer
and I don't think
I have one for you.
Zero.
The day I stopped
being a student,
my whole life changed forever.
I never had one bad day.
When I'm in pain I go to sleep
for five minutes
and I wake up the next
day and I kiss the world.
I don't give a fuck
about entrepreneurship.
I care about the
health of my parents
and my children and
my wife and this thing
called entrepreneurship
is easy as fuck.
I'm the best.
You understand?
So the reason I'm
dancing is I didn't want
to give you such a
ridiculous answer that
I know does not map.
I'm gonna end up
being the guy, my man.
When's it's all said
and done, when I die,
I'm gonna be on the fucking
pedestal at the tippy top.
That's not everybody.
So for me to give that
answer is very difficult
because I have pain.
There's always problems.
My brother walked
in and said "I quit.
"I have Chron's Disease.
I want to leave VaynerMedia.
"It's all on you."
That's not fun. That's hard
but it took me 8 seconds
to absorb and I started
smiling and saying good.
Just who I am.
So for me I was
dancing because I can't even
give you an answer
because every day's hard
and that's the
best fucking part of it
and so that's my truth.
(electronic music)